what about stage fright you know you
hear about greats like Carly Simon and
different people that you find out they
had stage fright at least if I article I
read was correct how do you overcome
stage fright is a great thing to have my
time now try and overcome it I'm like
here it shows you care unless you know
it blocks you unless it's shuts you down
but if stage fright can enhance the
performance it can give that extra
little silvery quality I would not try
and not have stage fright I would just
do the work and accept the stage fright
and you know if you've done the work the
stage fright will never be the thing
that will take over and will destroy
your performance if you've done the work
if you haven't done the work that's when
stage fright can really screw with you
so be prepared yeah and then stage
fright is a cool thing to have in there
it's part of the mix it's fine
you